yeah that's how was the British people
at least was spider-man I was on a set
once and we were talking about
spider-man and all I heard was
spider-man
so I'm putting these in totally
backwards to professional
[Music]
what's up reject nation my name is John
Humphrey and with me is my darling Kyle
Luhrmann that's correct
that's right Kyle I'll ermine of the
YouTube channel fan theory TV a lot of
good shows on there a lot of watch lungs
cooking different nerdy things and
whatnot Kyle is a comic book expert at
least in mark at least in marble what's
your favorite Iron Horse book no that's
dark I was like I've never even heard of
that brand sorry see I'm screwing up my
label but anyway we are gonna do one
other trailers revisited today we are
about to see ant-man and the wasp in a
couple hours actually at least at the
time of shooting this video so I thought
it would be a nice idea to go back and
to check out the trailer for the
original ant-man see how it holds up see
how it pitched the movie see if it gave
too much away gave away too little etc
you know the segment unless you don't in
which case that's what we do in this we
go back and see how good the trailer was
essentially this will be fun and before
we hop into this just want to give a
quick patron in the day shout-out to my
man mr. Curt Anderson Curt Anderson is a
lovely human being he all right yeah
that's the effect Curt it sounds it
sounds like neo from the matrix mister
and well I mean that's the thing is like
Curt used to be a normal guy right
mister
working and porn like you do not living
very healthy and then he woke up one day
man he read pilled himself and now he's
a nomad traveling the world living life
to the fullest not owning much for being
rich in spirit and this is just a great
big advertisement for how great Curt is
yeah so if you ever have the pleasure of
meeting Curt Anderson you should
probably hang out with I bet in his
travels he like if anyone's been to the
quantum realm it's probably Kurt or
another patron Jan Valente those are the
two people I can imagine would have been
to the quantum realm if that was
possible so Kurt dude sound stellar hope
you're doing well buddy we are gonna hop
into this here antman video I haven't
seen this probably since before the
ant-man movie came out yeah here we go
people join us
imagine a soldier the size of an insect
the ultimate super weapon you give that
like powers to everyone it's going to be
chaos a lot more intense that I remember
greatly know
oh yes Scott Oh flowertchi you for a
while you're like really building my
rosters a shot at redemption do you
absolutely my days of breaking into
places and stealing stuff
we want me to do I want you to break
into a place and steal some stuff make
sense oh are you ready to become the
hero power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are you greatest allies you're
kind of cute when you're small you have
superhuman strength
so you need to know how to punch them in
a bunch show me how that's a bunch you
tried to hide your suit from me now it's
gonna blow up in your face and destroy
everyone you can it's funny I got killed
[Music]
think you could stop the future I know
wasn't my idea
[Music]
so I would say that that trailer is
fairly accurate to the kind of movie
that they get except it's in many ways
more intense yeah it's way less humor
oriented that way that members way less
humor and it felt way more dramatic in
that trailer than the movie did which I
like about the movie actually I don't
mind that in terms of the trailer two
movies which are very sure I think I
only counted like three actual jokes in
this dream yes one of them is more of
kind of a self-conscious quip the whole
thing about like I want you to break
into a place and steal some stuff like
even that didn't play as an overt joke
joke
yeah in this trailer which actually kind
of surprised me going back just to look
at how much of an intense action movie
they tried to push this as it definitely
has those elements I feel like sure
ant-man is not a complete comedy to the
point where it doesn't fit with the MCU
at all but yeah I was a bit surprised by
that I do think they did a pretty good
job of not giving away much especially
if you haven't seen the movie you don't
know the context of all these different
set pieces watching it back I didn't
think like oh well thanks I've seen the
whole thing now yeah I think that was
the tricky part for me as I was trying
to like unsee the movie for a moment
while I was watching the trailer you
know the only real difference is it
seemed like Scott Lang they're really
good at editing it like he was embracing
it he's all on board and had nothing to
do with his own personal complex yeah
yeah his whole situation basically at
the time the movie kicks off yeah I'm
surprised like it doesn't give you as
much context about the Scott Lang story
actual main character yeah where he's
coming from it mostly just highlights
the adventure of becoming ant-man and
what the sort of military aspect of that
is the sort of micro Soldier element
yeah which I mean was still enough to
bring people I mean as if they weren't
gonna go there anyway way to be a Marvel
movie but it's harder to sell yeah
something based on a teeny little
character yeah yeah so they got it it
probably in the trailer make it more
intense because we have so many other
stories going on there so maybe that was
kind of their incentive I get it it's
told me if I ever seen it it sells you
on the aspects of the MCU you already
liked and are alright
tried-and-true if it was me I might have
gone with a slightly different angle for
this trailer but I understand the
position there and looking at the
ant-man the wasp advertising it seems
like the tones are a lot more evenly
represented watching this another thing
that struck me on that note is that you
see the action and it looks really cool
and it is very specific because you have
the ability of shrinking and blowing to
go with it but especially having seen
the ant-man of Lost Trailers lately it
seems like they've that much further
figured out how to really make that
shine as both an action tool and a tool
for humor yeah cuz you got that little
thing where he's like skating down the
street on the back of that truck and
things like that in the new trailer and
this trailer it's a little more just
like oh he's gonna shrink down and
that's kind of what makes it special
this time around they've already sold
you on the character at least in two
movie yes so I mean they're like now
we're gonna give you more of what you're
expecting from this trailer I think if
they went too intense for the second one
which they still go pretty intense I
mean ghostly it's pretty crazy I don't
think you're ever gonna get an ant-man
movie that is devoid of that live
intensive I just mean trailer wise it
has a good balance but they definitely
featured that comedy way more in this
new trailer feel like this trailer
encapsulates some of the situational
humor like with the Train and they're
small and right but not as much of the
banter based humor yeah you know cuz it
is actually kind of written like a
comedy then the new trailers they also
feature any of his team at all like
Michael Pena is at least in the ant-man
the wasp trailer and his buddies aren't
anywhere in here are they this is my fan
theory no you're the guy I honestly
think they're probably gonna be in like
one or two scenes tops I just don't
think they're gonna be like a huge part
of the overall story okay because I get
in ant-man in the original ant-man they
are a pretty prominent element of the
story element of a team in general and
not have this trailer at all like as a
viewer if I just you know seen this at
the time those characters are a cool
surprise right so it's kind of neat that
they kept them out of the trailer and
it's maybe a little much to try and
communicate to people and all that stuff
but yeah I think this is ultimately a
pretty good trailer and pretty
interesting your mark of the time and
place that it came out in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
yes I'm life
me at least looking back at I actually
think it was more effective for me now
than it was at the time just because it
was like ant-man really yeah yeah well
and I guess on the negative side of
things I can see that being kind of a
response to a trailer like this that
doesn't give you as much of a sense for
the true tone and the true motive which
is why I'm moving it why they went in
that direction for that trailer because
they need it to I feel like yeah I can
feel it from both angles because on the
one hand yeah you can't just be like
we're changing the script hope you dig
it cuz sometimes that doesn't work out
as well as you would have hoped but at
the same time I could see somebody
looking at a trailer like this and me
like what you know because it looks just
as intense and action-packed as any
other Marvel movie I can see somebody
being like a little guy who's big ants
what's what's going on here you know I
think Marvel likes to put little tidbits
of something fake to fear the audience
in a different direction kind of muddy
what your expectations are and there's
like at least one or two things I saw in
this trailer that definitely are
different than what the movie shows
especially the roof top part with
yellowjacket which is actually in the
movie with the Falcon okay hi I'm Scott
I feel like that's an interesting thing
to watch Marvel do too because now
they'll just like completely fabricates
divided into trailers
I almost appreciate the ingenuity of
just being like we're gonna cut around
to make it look like the context is
different at kind of respect that may be
slightly more just because you are using
technically all the stuff that's in the
movie yeah but I think Marvel does it
and I'm more hard to tell the difference
kind of way but this it's like they want
above and beyond and it looks like they
potentially fabricated a backdrop for
yellowjacket to be looking at a man in
that shot mm-hmm because I'm pretty sure
that's not in the movie yeah yeah I
think yellowjacket generally to Corey
Stoll like while yellowjacket isn't the
most memorable villain in terms of
motivations and whatnot I didn't think
Corey Stoll brought a lot to that role
and I think the main ensemble of the
cast is represented pretty well by this
trailer I mean Michael Douglas gets a
moment Evangeline Lilly gets a moment
and she actually left a big impression
on me from that movie right glad for
that that's a punch and what's great is
she actually signed up for the
only because they go right was on board
but now she's all in okay I may be alone
in this and I definitely don't want to
see like a Suicide Squad style Marvel
movie but I would be open to seeing a
lot of these villains just more just see
more of them that's the thing too is the
more of them we get in the more of them
get vanquished and pushed off to various
outcomes it would be almost nice to have
a sense for the community that is the
villains as much as you get the
community that is the heroes movies like
a real rogues get whenever I hear the
term rogues gallery I literally imagine
a gallery full of rogues
so like if I could imagine that for the
MCU I feel like that would be cool cuz
we don't want to go down the realm of
spider-man 3 where it's like you hate
spider-man so do i yeah let's team up we
don't want that yeah just in the sense
of the overall scope of the world I
don't want to have everything to be
trying to team up of thousand villains
to get your sinister 6 plotline going or
no ya know I feel like the groups need
to chill out a little well and it should
feel natural and there's nothing natural
about that yeah no no no this is an
interesting trailer to go back to
actually this is more interesting than I
thought it was gonna be just in terms of
the tone and how they pitched this yeah
I had actual chills and I've seen the
movie and yeah I've seen this trailer a
million times and yet I'm watching this
like trying to be seeing it with fresh
eyes and I was just like ooh this is
this looks good yeah what do you guys
think do you think they advertised Ant
Man pretty well with this or would you
rather seen a different take on the tone
let us know and as always you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time we review our videos out because
the subscribe button doesn't actually do
that who'da thunk check out the Kyler
men on Twitter and Instagram fan Theory
TV on the youtubes a lot of good content
over there and become a patron inject
today if you love us that much if you
want to get involved in our little
community got a lot of great people over
there we're doing full-length TV show
watch lungs we're doing music video
stuff all kinds of great content so if
you're interested we'd love you to come
check that out and as always be well
people and we'll see you for the next
one
Cheers